-Elle a grandi
dans une famille athée, de gauche,
avant de se convertir
au catholicisme
et c'est sa foi qui l'a amenée
à s'engager en politique
jusqu'à devenir porte-parole
du Rassemblement National.
Générique
...
-Bonjour, Mathilde Paris.
-Bonjour.
-Vous êtes aujourd'hui députée
du Rassemblement National
du Loiret.
J'ai été assez surpris
de découvrir
qu'après le 21 avril 2002,
quand Jean-Marie Le Pen
est arrivé
au 2nd tour de la présidentielle,
vous êtes
venue à Paris exprès pour manifester
contre Jean-Marie Le Pen,
contre le Front National à l'époque.
Pourquoi ?
-Je n'étais pas du tout, à l'époque,
de ce milieu-là
puisque j'ai grandi
dans une famille de gauche
et que, pour moi,
à cette époque,
le FN et Jean-Marie Le Pen,
c'était clairement
un danger
pour la République française,
notamment avec
ses déclarations qu'il avait pu
tenir par le passé.
Il y avait... une peur,
comme beaucoup de Français,
à l'époque...
Après, je concède
que je ne connaissais pas
le mouvement de l'intérieur.
J'en avais une vision extérieure
qui était rédhibitoire
et qui faisait qu'à aucun moment,
je n'aurais pensé,
un jour rejoindre ce parti
avec Marine Le Pen.
-Vous ne vous êtes pas
tout de suite engagée.
Votre 1er engagement politique
remonte à 2009.
Ce n'était pas
pour le Front National.
Vous avez pris votre carte
au MPF, le Mouvement
Pour la France
de Philippe de Villiers.
Vos grands-parents maternels
et votre mère étaient de gauche.
Votre mère a même fait partie
des jeunesses communistes.
Comment ont-ils vécu
votre engagement au MPF ?
-Le MPF, quand même,
ça passait mieux que le FN,
clairement, mais c'est sûr
que c'était pas tout à fait...
du tout,
sur la même idée politique...
-Ils vous en ont voulu ?
Ca a créé des disputes ?
-Je dirais pas que ça a créé
des disputes
mais plus de l'incompréhension.
Mon grand-père, surtout, était
attristé de se dire : "Ben mince...
"Elle est partie de l'autre côté !"
Mais après,
pour autant,
c'était quand même...
Ils savaient que je n'étais
ni raciste ni...
Ils savaient qui j'étais.
Ils étaient quand même rassurés
là-dessus.
-Vous êtes donc passée en quelques
années d'une manifestation
contre J-M. Le Pen à un engagement
pour Philippe de Villiers.
Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
pour opérer une telle bascule
politique ?
-L'événement important,
c'est que je suis partie
aux Etats-Unis en tant qu'étudiante,
en immersion dans une famille
d'accueil.
J'ai fait le lycée américain.
Ca été un peu un électrochoc
d'être loin de la France.
J'ai pris conscience
à ce moment-là
de ce que c'était
que d'être français,
de notre héritage,
de la richesse,
cette richesse patrimoniale
et historique de notre pays,
notre culture,
notre art de vivre,
ce qui faisait
notre identité propre.
J'ai pris conscience
qu'en tant que Français,
on n'avait pas cette notion-là,
qu'on ne nous la donnait pas
suffisamment
que ce soit l'école
ou dans le cercle familial
et je me suis dit :
ce n'est pas possible aujourd'hui
que la jeunesse de France
n'aie pas conscience
de la chance qu'elle a
d'être française,
de la richesse qu'est ce pays
et pour laquelle il faut se battre.
-Un autre événement a bouleversé
votre vie durant cette période
et c'est votre conversion
au catholicisme.
Vous expliquez que la religion
vous a aidée à traverser
une épreuve personnelle.
Si j'en parle,
c'est parce que vous faites le lien
entre votre conversion
et votre engagement politique.
Pourquoi ?
-Eh bien ça a été...
Très clairement, j'ai failli mourir.
J'ai été anorexique.
Je n'ai pas peur de le dire.
Si je n'avais pas eu
cette conversion,
je pense que je ne serais plus
de ce monde.
Ca a été...
J'ai tellement reçu
que j'ai eu ce besoin
de me donner aux autres
et le meilleur moyen de servir,
pour moi,
c'était l'engagement politique.
Et là,
ça a été effectivement mon adhésion
au Front National de l'époque,
lorsque Marine est arrivée
à la tête du parti...
-Ca, ça s'est fait en 2011.
Ca correspond au moment
où elle prend la présidence
du parti.
-Oui, j'ai franchi le cap
à l'arrivée de Marine.
-C'est ce qui vous a
convaincue de rejoindre
le Front National, ce changement
de présidence ?
-Pour moi,
Marine avait fait le ménage
dans le parti pour enlever
tous ceux qui avaient un profil
sulfureux et qui posaient,
pour moi, un problème.
Et elle était...
Son discours me satisfaisait,
et elle avait cet équilibre,
par rapport à mon histoire,
ayant grandi dans une famille
de gauche, un équilibre
entre un aspect social important.
Elle a vraiment une fibre sociale.
Et en même temps,
la fibre de défendre ce que c'est
que la France, nos idéaux,
nos valeurs...
-De fil en aiguille,
vous avez fini par vous présenter
aux élections municipales
à Blois en 2014.
Vous avez été élu conseillère
municipale
puis conseillère régionale en 2015.
Vous avez échoué
aux législatives en 2017
dans le Loir-et-Cher
et, cinq ans plus tard,
vous avez été élue
dans le Loiret.
En parallèle,
vous avez eu une carrière
professionnelle,
en charge du mécénat
au château
de Chambord.
Quand est-ce que la politique
a pris le dessus
sur cette carrière professionnelle ?
-Le déclic, je dirais,
ça a été dans les années
2017-2018.
J'ai donné naissance à mon 3e enfant
et, clairement, ça devenait
compliqué de gérer à la fois
une vie politique,
une vie familiale
et une vie professionnelle
en tant que salariée
avec des horaires...
Un rythme quand même assez strict,
on va dire.
Ca devenait difficile
de tout mener de front.
A ce moment-là, j'ai créé
ma propre entreprise
parce que je ne me voyais pas
ne faire que de la politique.
J'ai toujours eu besoin
d'avoir quelque chose à côté.
-La suite est directement
liée à Jordan Bardella
parce qu'il vous a nommée
au bureau national
du RN puis porte-parole
du parti.
C'est assez compliqué à assumer
comme fonction.
Il faut savoir répondre
à toutes les questions,
à tous les imprévus possibles.
Est-ce qu'on vous a formée
avant de vous lancer
dans le grand bain ?
-Formée, pas spécialement.
J'avais déjà eu...
Il y avait une petite formation
quand j'étais membre
du bureau national
avant que Jordan
ne prenne la responsabilité
de la présidence du mouvement
mais après...
Je pense qu'il avait détecté
que j'avais une aisance orale,
j'avais déjà fait
pour les législatives...
On a tous étés amenés
à passer sur des plateaux
à un moment.
-Chaque porte-parole
développe son style.
Il y en a qui sont
très puncheurs,
d'autres plus pédagos
pour expliquer...
On vous voit
avec le porte-parole du groupe RN,
Kévin Mauvieux.
Quel est votre style,
comme porte-parole ?
-Moi,
j'essaie de parler
de la vraie vie des gens.
J'ai envie d'être ce porte-voix
de la ruralité.
J'habite dans un territoire rural.
Je le vis au quotidien.
C'est important de donner une voix
à tous ces invisibles
de la société française.
Etre leur porte-voix,
c'est ça qui me...
-En 2015, tout juste élue
au conseil régional,
il y a une image qui a marqué
un peu les médias locaux.
Vous vous êtes rendue
à la 1re session
avec votre fille, encore petite,
et vous l'avez allaitée
pendant la séance.
C'était un geste féministe
pour vous, de faire ça ?
-C'était pour moi
quelque chose de naturel.
-Je l'avais fait aussi
pour mon 1er bébé,
au conseil municipal de Blois...
Là, on vous voit en photo
dans une cérémonie officielle
avec...
-J'avais l'habitude de porter
mes bébés en écharpe
et de les allaiter
les 6 premiers mois,
comme c'est recommandé.
Pour moi, en tant que femme...
On veut que les femmes
s'investissent en politique.
On a fait beaucoup avec la parité
sur les listes électorales
mais il faut aussi
que l'on puisse
être pleinement mères,
pleinement engagées
dans nos mandats électifs.
Et ça, ça a encore
du mal à passer.
Je me suis pris des réflexions
de la part de la majorité
de gauche du conseil régional,
qui voyait
d'un mauvais oeil en disant :
"Ce n'est pas le lieu", etc.
Il fallait que je me cache.
On a beaucoup à faire
pour faire accepter
qu'une mère
peut allaiter son enfant
dans l'espace public.
-C'est un geste féministe ?
-Je ne le fais pas forcément
en me disant que je fais
du militantisme féminisme.
Mais c'est une forme de féminisme,
pour moi, effectivement.
-Vous avez un collègue du groupe RN
qui ne partage visiblement pas
votre conception de la place
des femmes dans la société.
Je voulais vous faire réagir
à ce qu'il a dit
lors débat sur le projet de loi
pour le plein emploi.
*-Nous, nous partons du principe
qu'une mère au foyer,
elle est peut-être mieux
à la maison
à s'occuper de ses enfants
plutôt...
Protestations dans l'hémicycle
Eh oui, mais bien sûr,
n'en déplaise
à mes collègues,
Si elle le souhaite,
il vaut mieux
qu'elle reste à la maison
à s'occuper de ses enfants,
si elle le souhaite,
plutôt qu'elle aille...
Plutôt que vous l'envoyiez
dans un dispositif
où elle va devoir réaliser
15 heures d'activité.
-Ca doit vous mettre
hors de vous, ça !
Non ? Ca ne...
-Au début, parce que
je n'ai eu que le début...
Il y a eu une polémique
sur les réseaux.
C'est vrai, j'ai un peu bondi.
Mais j'ai compris le contexte,
par rapport aux heures de RSA
qu'on voulait imposer,
les heures de service...
-On a l'impression
qu'il répond de façon
spontanée et qu'il se reprend,
se disant qu'il a dit une bêtise.
-C'était surtout de la maladresse
de sa part.
Effectivement,
il ne s'agit pas d'imposer
aux femmes de rester au foyer.
On est beaucoup à être contentes
d'avoir une vie à côté
et c'est une source d'épanouissement
pour nous, aussi.
En 2014, vous avez qualifié
l'avortement
de crime contre l'humanité
en le comparant aux mécanismes
mis en place
par l'idéologie nazie.
Ce sont les termes
que vous aviez employés à l'époque.
Vous faites partie des 33 députés
qui ont voté
contre la constitutionnalisation
du droit à l'IVG.
On peut être féministe
et s'opposer au droit des femmes
à disposer de leur corps ?
-Je réfute
le terme "droit des femmes
à disposer de leur corps"
parce que,
si vous voulez...
-Pour vous, l'IVG, c'est pas...
-Il y a un être humain
en construction
donc on est pas seuls
dans cette histoire.
C'est important de le rappeler.
Je m'inscris plus
dans la ligne de Simone Veil.
Personne ne dira
que Simone Veil
était contre le droit des femmes.
Le droit à l'avortement
a été complètement dévoyé.
Elle avait mis des garde-fous
et voulait que ce soit le dernier
recours quand on avait étudié
toutes les solutions possibles
pour garder un enfant.
Ce qui me choque, c'est
qu'on ne fait rien pour aider
les femmes, justement, soit à avoir
des moyens de contraception.
C'est un vrai sujet.
Beaucoup de femmes, maintenant,
ont une espèce de...
de défiance vis-à-vis de la pilule
et des moyens de contraception.
donc beaucoup de femmes n'utilisent
plus ces moyens de contraception
et, effectivement, se retrouvent
dans des situations compliquées.
Et il y a aussi la question
de la responsabilisation des hommes
parce qu'un bébé,
on ne le fait jamais toute seule.
Souvent, on élude cette partie-là
parce que c'est évidemment
la femme qui, derrière,
assume toutes les conséquences,
seule, très souvent,
d'un avortement
et je pense qu'il y a
beaucoup de choses à faire,
pour aider les femmes,
pour responsabiliser les hommes,
et rien n'est fait.
Et justement,
cette constitutionnalisation
de l'IVG
ne va absolument pas régler
ces problèmes.
-On va passer à un sujet
plus léger,
notre quiz, à présent.
Je vais vous proposer
des débuts de phrases
et vous allez devoir les compléter.
"Avec Sandrine Rousseau,
"je partage..."
-Je dirais...
pas grand-chose.
La cause des femmes ?
Mais on n'a pas le même
positionnement,
c'est certains !
Elle rit.
-On l'a compris.
-Mais quand même ce combat
féministe, on va dire.
Chacun à sa façon.
"Dans mon camping-car, je..."
Je vais à la rencontre
des habitants
de ma circonscription.
J'ai choisi de faire
une permanence mobile.
Je me déplace chaque semaine
dans une commune différente
de ma circonscription
qui est assez étendue.
Aujourd'hui, les gens sont
de plus en plus méfiants
vis-à-vis de la politique
et d'aller à leur rencontre,
ça permet de faire
de la politique autrement.
-"Entre porte-paroles,
"on se dit souvent..."
-Alors là...
-Vous parlez entre vous,
j'imagine,
après les émissions.
-Oui...
Après, honnêtement...
Je pense qu'entre porte-parole,
on est quand même assez solidaires.
On est sur la même ligne,
y a pas de souci.
-Merci, Mathilde Paris,
d'être venue dans l'émission.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...